[Música]
é eu vim aqui hoje contar uma história
de amor quem gosta de história de amor
todo mundo gosta né é de um casal
chamado duda e adelina rodolphe a melina
que se conheceram lá nos anos quarenta e
sete e quando noivaram se apaixonaram
muito lhe sempre florida eterna missão
eternamente apaixonados até hoje eu acho
e resolveram noivar quando não vai
escrever um livro que tenha livro de
noivos naquela época tinha que eles
queriam ter 20 filhos e eles só tiveram
16 é e eu então começa eu sou a cesta de
se desse grupo e isto acontece numa
pequena cidade chamada luiz alves no
interior de santa catarina
eles tinham um negócio pequeno negócio
de secos e molhados que naquela cidade
vendia tudo vende a roupa vendia o
alimento vendia as coisas pra casa
vendia tecido em 1957 eu já tinha
nascido
a minha mãe grávida claro do do 7º não
pode vir a são paulo fazer as compras
quem venceu duda o poeta
ela era empreendedor e ele era o poeta
como bom poeta ele comprou um tecido
errado quem calhou ao invés de fazer
drama a dona adelina viu ali o que é uma
oportunidade ela pegou esse tecido
contratou duas costureiras e não só uma
camisa e ela começa a costurar primeiro
dentro de casa depois alugar uma casinha
lá na frente e ali então começa a
história da dudalina e eu conto que ela
a minha mãe nunca existiu nunca vi a
minha mãe aceitar ou não facilmente
lembro que era pequena foi uma vez já
com muito pequenininha fui com ela vem
de camisas anterior alcançada queria
voltar a grávida ela falou filho só vou
voltar quando
vender a última camisa então pra mim eu
sempre falo não eu já tenho
eu vou sempre à procura do sim e essa
história continua online icesave depois
ela dá uma casa de presente pra nós em
camboriú
nós ficamos um ano só os filhos nessa
casa de férias
você tem idéia do que é 12 14 crianças
todas juntas
como é fácil lidar então o que ela fez
ela comprou uma loja meu pai comprou uma
loja em camboriú ou e as filhas
trabalhavam com a minha mãe durante o
verão e os filhos com o pai
isso fazia com que ela tinha dinheiro
naquela época só tinha essas lojas em
camboriú para investir na fábrica e
assim foi os filhos o crescendo
precisava estudar em blumenau a história
começou a ficar cara quando ela estava
consciente já indo pro pudesse um sexto
filho então ela resolve mudar com a
família inteira para blumenau
aqui começa uma nova fase os filhos já
estão mais envolvidos nos negócios cada
irmão de alguma forma passou pelo
processo da dudalina quando chegou em
dois incidentes em 34 gente quando eu
falo essas datas eu eu fiquei assustada
comigo tá no meu irmão foi para a
espanha compra uma tecnologia chamou
falou precisa e duas moças
eu fui aprender a tecnologia implantei
na do d'ale na em 77 essa empresa da
espanha então me convida para trabalhar
para eles no brasil e era o meu grande
sonho é sair de casa do meio daquele já
era jovem já tinha jogos já tinha 21
anos
eu era pelé era diretora da empresa mas
eu falei não eu vou nessa vou aprender
vou sair de casa lembra que é uma outra
frase que eu gosto muito perguntei pra
uma pessoa
o senhor acha que eu devo e ele falou se
você for você pode se arrepender
mas se você não for você vai se
arrepender o resto da sua vida
eu nunca me arrependi fui inclusive eu
achei que era pra fortaleza me mandaram
para montes claros em minas gerais foi
barbada o trabalho em um ano
na fábrica como chefe das instrutoras de
lá eu quis mudar para belo horizonte foi
a belo horizonte
eu tentava abrir um negócio alguém me
contratava então abrir várias fábricas
até que quando chegou à final de 83 eu
falei agora eu quero morar em são paulo
quero sequer ir para grande capital não
tinha emprego que levava um emprego e
tal
meus irmãos humberto então falar sobre a
volta e abriu escritório em são paulo
monta a estrutura de venda naquela época
que mandava nos grandes magazines
aqui quem é um pouco vocês são muito
jovens mas sim é merda a firmeza no rio
cias mapping é c e ainda tá aí então eu
vim
morando em são paulo indo para santa
catarina que a empresa em blumenau e
todas as semanas que esse caminho então
eu sempre eu fui da produção durante um
tempo depois durante outro tempo eu fui
da de mercado de de abrir mercado depois
eu fui produto é então sempre tive muito
envolvida é em toda a estrutura da
empresa sempre sempre muito interessado
e que eu tinha uma característica que é
eu brincava com a minha mãe até sobre
isso que falar amanhã acho que a senhora
teve tantos filhos para ter uma mão de
obra bem barata né porque a gente
trabalhava desde criança é lá em
camboriú ainda voltando lá era melhor
vendedor a dell tinha 89 anos e mais
adorava vender eu sempre adorei vender
sempre adorei trabalhar isso acho que
ela ela moldou os 16 filhos é o meu pai
porque era muito meu pai era emoção pura
eu falo com o meu pai nunca me deu um
presente físico mas ele me deu poesias
as poesias eu tenho até hoje todas num
livro então eu falo que a gente quando
há crianças você não entende né depois
com o tempo você vê que essa história
está escrita para a eternidade
então nessa nessa vidas e vindas
a gente já tinha uma gol
é dança né são eram 16 sócios a minha
mãe teve uma inteligência emocional
extremamente incrível ela eo pai eles
passaram tudo para os filhos lá em 84
ela saiu da executiva da empresa e foi
trabalhar com o que restava dos retalhos
da empresa fazendo o patchwork fazendo
inclusão e trabalhando todo esse lado
social
meu pai faleceu em 96
isso eu tô voltando lá mas voltando
agora a atual época em 2008 essa grande
mulher faleceu e até ali
nós éramos uma família a partir daquele
momento mas nos tornamos 16 famílias são
os meninos e 15 meninas nem todos os
meninos são tão bonzinhos
nem todas as minas são tão bonzinhos
tudo bem que hoje tem uma harmonia
gigante amo minhas irmãs e paixão é mais
nessa época foi uma época em pouco
misson época um pouco mais turbulenta
porque a grande matriarca não estava
mais no meio o meu pai quando era vivo
em que me dado uma missão que era
complexa tá lá no livro da minha mãe que
eu ser embaixatriz da paz
alguém quer ficar aqui no meio de 16
irmãos 15 irmãos né então eu tinha essa
missão
então era bem complicado lidar com isso
mas eu tava lá eu era eu estava
presidente da dudalina num eu sempre
respondia um conselho sempre responde
aos acionistas eu não tinha essa
arrogância de achar que eu era dono e
mandava sozinha sempre tive isso com
muito respeito porque quem é dono do
negócio mesmo que fosse acionistas eram
os meus irmãos querem os acionistas em
dentro disso um irmão meu que era diz
era presidente comigo ele resolve numa
dessas dessas coisas que a gente não
gosta que acontece na vida ele resolve
sair da empresa e vai seguir o caminho
dele mas não foi simples assim
ele sai da empresa mas aí foi ao mesmo
tempo fantástico porque eu vejo ali uma
oportunidade única de transformar tudo
nós até ali nós éramos uma indústria de
camisas masculinas vendíamos as nossas
marcas no interior do brasil
e fazemos muito próprio equilíbrio
dessas marcas como blue shield regras do
evento na zona aquela época
então nós éramos mas a gente não tinha
visibilidade ea gente é não tinha uma
marca com mesquinha marca mas não era
comercial junho tinha ido pro farias
novamente em 2010 eu sei lá um dia eu
não sou estilista mas eu cheguei na
empresa para a gente eu quero mudar isso
aqui tudo chama em pessoal do estilo eu
quero fazer uma coleção para mulheres de
camisas para mulheres não traz todos os
tecidos que a gente tem todos os
alimentos vão há que criar uma coleção
eu queria uma coleção muito rápidas um
claro que uma equipe maravilhosa que eu
tinha é eu falei com ele que eu faço
isso para mostrar público na época o
joão dória tinha que de shopping lá em
campos do jordão quer um shopping que
sabia durante dois meses no inverno
liguei para ele e falei sempre vendo um
espaço e vendeu eu fui lá fiz essa loja
tem casa lá ficou fácil eu primeiro dia
que abriu a loja já era um absurdo no
segundo dia a pessoa comprou uma na no
dia anterior e ela comprava 3 trazia
manhã a tia eu acho que nem com eles
encontrados na rua elevado na loja
então eu fiz o melhor teste de mercado
que eu podia ter porque eu estava com a
barriga no balcão eu estava vendo que eu
estava fazendo e eu no outro dia segunda
filha pra fábrica aí vão mudar esse
negócio aqui vamos lançar uma coleção
feminina
vamos contratar mais pessoas
principalmente eu só quero mulheres
nessa nessa linha e edu na sua mísera
gente vamos fazer vai dar certo e isso
tudo eu trabalhava na minha sala
iluminar uma salário gigante não tinha
portas então toda a gente desse dia todo
mundo me pergunta como é que chegou a
flor de lys o meu um dos meus estilistas
na época
o gerente de produto e v eu cheguei para
ele explicar todo produto ali eu quero
um símbolo da nossa marca
de um lado a gente vamos criar um
símbolo que naquele mesmo dia ele chega
na minha mesa e fala dona sônia aqui ó
flor de lys e aí começa então a surgir a
camisaria feminina em 2000 é e 10 e ea
gente lança a flor de lys a gente lança
isso dá muito certo em 2011 abrindo 30
lojas 2012 70 2013 sem lojas e aqui eu
tenho que passar por um processo muito
complexo da minha vida
conseguimos vender essa empresa porque
tinha uma necessidade assunto dizendo a
família eram muito grandes
ok vendemos a empresa eu continue
presidente mas em 2015 eu saí da empresa
foi o concelho mas ali aconteceu foi
feito uma fusão com a restoque mas ali
aconteceu uma coisa que era o meu sonho
eu vou me dedicar ao terceiro setor 2013
a gente já tinha começado o grupo
mulheres do brasil nesta aqui agora é e
estão lá as mulheres do brasil mulheres
do brasil aqui é
[Aplausos]
a gente tinha começado esse grupo a e eu
sempre eu eu eu sempre quis devolver à
sociedade aquilo que eu quero construir
então comecei realmente me dedicar o
terceiro setor
a educação que eu acho que é um é a
única forma de salvar o nosso país a
educação então eu estou lá na fundação
dom cabral mas também todo verde escola
também todo o instituto ayrton sena
através das mulheres eu falo que nós
somos 50% mas somos mães bill dos outros
50%
então acho que através de nós nós
podemos mudar o brasil
e hoje eu tô muito feliz porque eu
acordo de manhã tendo a certeza de que
eu tenho que fazer algo para mudar o meu
país eu tenho transformar esse país que
a gente vive que a gente ama
num país melhor então eu me dedico
bastante a isso eu acabo me envolvendo
em várias causas que às vezes eu falo
meu deus porque eu fiz só tem mais um
conselho tem mais um grupo de mentoria
eu tô fazendo palestras
mas deus me deu graças a deus essa
bênção de hoje poder estar aqui contando
pra vocês
essa história que começa lá atrás uma
mulher empreendedora chamada de lina com
lindomar i duda que fizeram dudalina e
seus 16 filhos e hoje estar aqui falando
para vocês e contando o tanto que eu
ainda quero me dedicar o meu país o
tanto que eu quero ajudar a transformar
lo
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]